today on the matt wall show i have an
idea a plan
for how to proceed how to get things
going again again
and it involves you know everybody
making their own decisions
personal responsibility is what we used
to call it
and i will outline that today also five
headlines including millions of
americans uh now considering
homeschooling
for the first time so we'll talk about
that and in our daily cancellation
we will cancel two of the dumbest
criminals
in world history possibly and they
happen to be nfl players
uh perhaps not surprisingly so all of
that coming up
all right um and also i should mention
at the top
just because that i really really need a
haircut it's it's getting
the situation is getting bad i am
getting precariously close to
ponytail territory in the back here i
could almost
um make a ponytail almost
and that has brought me precariously
close to
uh actually allowing my wife to cut my
hair and i have i've held off for two
months
bravely boldly not allowing it and the
reason i won't allow her to do it is
because
i know that at least part of her would
be tempted to take the clippers and just
go right off the top of my head just
buzz cut right off the top
and i know she'd be tempted to do that
because i would be tempted to do that if
i was her
so there would at least be that
temptation and i could never be
probably only about a five percent
chance she would actually do it
and then i also know yes it would be
hilarious if i had to go do the show the
next day
with uh you know with with totally
mangled hair so i would kind of
appreciate the humor
but at the same time it would ruin my
life so
that's situation um hopefully we can get
the uh the the barber shops open again
and you know mainly not because of uh
people like me need haircuts because we
look like mangy dogs but mainly because
people who run barbershops and hair
salons and so on you know they need to
make a living i think that's probably
the more important thing so
as we talk about opening up and
everything there's there's been a lot of
debate about
whether people should wear masks and
whether it's really effective or not to
wear masks
and whether businesses should require it
of their customers or not um you know
personally it seems clear to me that
mandating the use of face masks
outside as some localities have done
like in los angeles for example
is absurd at best i mean the best thing
you can say about is absurd there's no
reason to think
that you're at any appreciable risk of
contracting or spreading the disease
when you're outside outdoors especially
if you're maintaining a comfortable
distance from other groups now on the
other hand
there does seem to be reason to think
that running or
cycling or jogging or exercising outside
in the heat with a mask strapped to your
face
and collecting sweat and spit as you go
is not the most hygienic practice you
know i've done no
scientific research into this i admit i
have no
data whatsoever but i'm guessing
that when presented with a choice
between exercising while breathing into
a spittle soaked rag
or exercising without the rag the latter
choice will generally be healthier and
more sanitary
that's i'm guessing now
does that mean that people shouldn't
wear masks in my opinion
in my anti-mask okay now this is one of
those things
we all have to be anti-mask or pro mask
no i'm neither i have really no opinion
on
on what other people decide to do with
their faces you can do whatever you want
with your face
cover the whole thing in a mask you can
walk around with it with a pillow case
over your head if you want to it doesn't
matter to me
i acknowledge a business owner's right
to require masks in his establishment
and i'll comply with those requirements
out of respect
to the private property rights of a
business owner uh
outside of that i'm probably not going
to wear one
my opinion on masks is like my opinion
on most other crotavirus precautions
make your own decision and live your
life
and godspeed it's it's just it's not
clear to me why there needs to be a
consensus
or a universal strategy that we all
adopt when it comes to this
now yes you could argue that masks are
more effective if everybody else wears
them too
but if they're effective at all if they
have any effect
they should still offer you a
significant amount of protection um
regardless of who else has them on like
if you're
if you're going to store something
and you have a mask on and you're
maintaining social distance
and you're not lingering very much
you're going in getting what you need
and you're leaving
even if nobody else in the store has a
mask on yeah it's not perfect protection
but it should offer you some protection
should make a difference if you're
telling me that masks make no difference
at all unless
everybody has them then it sounds like
masks are pretty ineffective anyway
so what's the point somewhere along the
line we decided that the coronavirus
threat is one threat
that we all have to respond to in the
exact same way
without exception but that is not how
this country generally functions and it
shouldn't start now
so so why can't this be the way forward
those who wish to wear masks wear them
those who don't wish to wear masks don't
wear them
businesses that wish to require masks
require them
businesses that don't wish to require
them don't
businesses that wish to remain closed
remain closed businesses that
businesses that wish to open up can open
up
people who wish to stay locked in their
homes indefinitely stay locked in their
home indefinitely
people who wish to go outside of their
homes will go outside of their homes
see these are all matters of risk
assessment
so a combination of factors have to be
weighed
and that that calculation
can be complicated for every individual
depending on your
situation that calculation though is
downright impossible
if we're treating 330 million people as
if they are one homogenous
single entity when they're not the
calculation is going to be different for
everybody
depending on their situation and that's
the point
i think there are some people personally
it seems to me there are some people who
for them it makes a lot of sense to
stay inside as much as possible wear a
mask when you go out
there are some people like that
people who are elderly people who have
pre pre-existing conditions
but that's not everybody why do we have
to pretend that everybody is the same
uh and why is it that people who usually
are all about extolling the virtue of
of choice suddenly have abandoned that
uh when it comes to this
we'll talk about that more in just a
second but first
um you know ancestry.com i've i've done
this myself and with ancestrydna
learning about our family ancestry where
we come from
and uh you know i was i'll be honest
with you i was a little bit worried at
first when i
when i started because i heard of so
many people doing this and i was worried
that i'd be disappointed that it
wouldn't live up to the hype but it
definitely did
and it's just been fascinating to learn
about my own family and
where i came from how it is that i ended
up this way which i think is a question
a lot of people have
there are many paths to finding your
family story whichever way you choose
tracing your family generations back
with a family tree or uncovering your
ethnicity with ancestry dna
whatever it is it's easy to get started
with ancestry an ancestry dna test tells
you
where your ancestors are from uh and
ancestry's billions of records and
millions of family trees
let you discover their personal stories
researching a history is a fun activity
it's something that involves the whole
family you know i know my kids
especially been very interested to find
out as well
and the stories you learned about you
learn about can you know be shared and
it gives you something to talk about
um around the dinner table and with your
families
so uh if you haven't if you've never
tried this before i would absolutely
recommend it you could trace the paths
of your recent ancestors
learn how and why your family moved from
place to place around the world just
learning the story
of your family start exploring your
family story today head to
my url at ancestry.com matt to get your
ancestry dna kit
and start your free trial that's
ancestry.com
ancestry.com
um okay
so this this this is my point this much
seems obvious to me
if you remain shut inside your home
indefinitely
and you only emerge for brief moments
fully masked just to go to the grocery
store
you're probably not going to get sick
you'll also be living a kind of dreary
life
not a life that i want to live but but
that's that's my own perspective
and who cares what my perspective is you
can live that life if you want to
you are free to be a reclusive
hypochondriac if that's the sort of
existence
that you prefer the point is that
there's no reason to require
the same existence of everyone even if
all the rest of us
are running around you know coughing in
each other's faces
kissing strangers on the mouth whatever
it is
you will be safe shut in your home
sheltered from the germ orgy that's
happening out there
so you don't need to worry about it so
so why not make this
our reopening strategy another term for
this strategy is personal responsibility
also liberty
it's the strategy we've employed for
most
other diseases most of the time
if you're very fearful of this disease
it doesn't matter if anyone else
thinks that your fear is overblown or
justified
i think that's where a lot of the
tension and the argument and the
division is coming from
where we think that we have our opinion
of this disease and the threat that it
poses and we think that everyone else
has to feel the same way about it they
don't it doesn't matter it shouldn't
matter at least they shouldn't have to
feel the same way
if you're fearful of it you have your
reasons great well not great i mean i'm
sorry that you're fearful but but
you you can live accordingly you're
entitled to your fear
you're entitled to whatever strategies
you put in place for its sake
but your fear is not entitled to dictate
my life
that's the point now i know you can
dream up
scenarios where even if you're locked in
your house someone can get you sick
uh and i've it is someone someone today
told me that um
or yesterday when i was talking about
this someone said
oh well that's the old canard of well
that's great for you but
your choices might kill my parents
and i said how are my choices going to
kill your parents if i'm if i'm out
doing my thing and they're shut in their
house because they want a shelter in
place and it seems like
how could i have any effect on them the
only way i could have any effect on them
is if they choose to go out and
participate in society and if they if
they choose that then they choose to
take on the risk
and that's it and then i was told
well uh you could get a mail carrier
sick
and then he could deliver mail to my
parents and the virus could get on the
mail
and my parents could touch the the mail
and then get sick
okay that's
that's how extreme that's how tortured
people are getting in trying to explain
how or why everybody has to stay locked
in their home
because you might you might get a mail
carrier sick or somehow
transmit the viru transmits the virus by
mail
to someone who's locked in their home i
mean come on
the other argument i've heard a lot in
the last couple of days
is um that
if we're going to take this approach of
everyone you know assess their own risk
level
and live accordingly then by that logic
well it almost seems like you're saying
we shouldn't have seat belt laws or we
shouldn't have smoking bans
and actually funnily enough yes that's
how i feel
and that's that's actually a great
comparison i think the seat belt law
comparison is very good
because let me tell you how i feel about
seat belt laws i think they're
completely ridiculous
and nothing but a fundraising mechanism
for the state
there is no reason why we need cops
going around looking for people that
don't have seat belts on so they can
charge them 50 bucks for not having a
seat
if you want to drive down the road
without a seatbelt on that's your choice
it's your risk
you're not putting anybody else at risk
and uh and you know no problem
you you should be able to choose to take
on that risk
except even with that you know that's a
very that's actually a generous com
comparison for the pro-lockdown side
because
at least with at least with seat belts
although i
believe that people should be able to
take on that risk if they want to
and there's no reason why we need daddy
you know
daddy's state out there daddy police
officer out there
lecturing us to keep our seatbelts on
but at least there you know this the
science is pretty well established
um there's very little controversy that
you're you are safer with seat belts
anyway
most of the time now you could argue if
you're going very slow you get into a
fender bender you might be better off
without the seat belt because if you
have it on
you could get whiplash or something i
don't know i mean there's but generally
speaking
you're better off with the seat belt on
that's pretty well established science
the thing with the lockdown though is
not only should people have the right to
assess their own risk
but it's by no means a foregone
conclusion
that this lockdown strategy is actually
the safest
so it's it's not just
that people aren't being given the right
to assess their own risk
but it's that we are being forced to us
to accept
the risk assessment of government
officials
and scientists who are on the
government's payroll we're being forced
to accept
their assessment when their assessment
is at a minimum
highly controversial and there's a whole
other way of looking at it
so that's the point but either way it
goes back to as i said
you can be as scared as you want whether
your fear is justified or not is not the
point
but your fear does not dictate choices
in my life or at least it shouldn't
let's go to headlines um a camera uh
a camera guy from a new york news
channel was at a lockdown protest
and the video was shared by kevin vesey
from news 12 in new york
and uh he said as he shared it on
twitter the level of anger directed at
the media from these protesters was
alarming
and a bunch of other media people shared
the video as well shaking their heads
and disappointment and indignation and
all the mean things that
people in this video said about the the
media but if you listen to it
i don't know i listened to it and
everything seemed pretty accurate to me
so take take a listen to this
i'm just trying to get by on the
sidewalk that's all you shouldn't be
here
you stop you stopped airing the trump
briefings and you keep airing cuomo
briefings go home
we know about your liberal agenda we
know you want to keep your job we get it
you're not getting
dollars in right now you want it you're
not going to
[Music]
i don't know what happened to
tell the you kevin come on essential
big news
i gotta say i can't find fault with
anything that was said there
it just where where's the lie tell me
where the lie
is it shows you the whole problem with
the media
though doesn't it that rather than think
to themselves
geez people really hate us
what have we done wrong okay what have
we done
what are we doing wrong that people feel
this way about us rather than saying
that
which is which is the the question that
a self-aware person would ask themselves
rather than that they say oh geez people
really hate us there must be something
wrong with them
number two nfl announcer joe buck says
that it's quite likely the nfl season
will go forward
without fans in the stadium but he
indicates some other adjustments that
might be made he said in an interview
quote i think fox and these networks
have to put crowd noise under us to make
it a normal viewing experience at home
i think whoever is going to be at the
control is going to have to be really
good at their job and be realistic
with how a crowd would react depending
on what just happened on the field
so what's really important and then he
also said on top of the crowd noise that
they might pump in
at least to the broadcast they might
have cgi he indicated they've talked
about doing this well
they'll have cgi people in the stands
so it looks like a full stadium and this
of course is all a very terrible idea
if anything you get more mics down on
the field so we can hear the action
you know on the sideline on the on the
field that might be interesting
might get a little dicey too with the
language i admit
um and or or you know of course the
other option
is just play the games
have people in the stands let people
come to the games
it's outdoors at least most stadiums are
even the indoor stadiums are obviously
very big so there's plenty of air
circulation
i don't i really don't see any reason
why you have to not have people in the
stands
or at a minimum you got a 70 000 person
stadium
sell 40 000 tickets or 35 000 tickets
and then there's plenty of space people
can spread out not a problem
number three the new york post reports
quote a black professor
driving in vermont with new york license
plates was flagged down by two white men
and told to leave the state in what
police are investigating as a
bias-related incident according to a
report
the unidentified professor was driving
with his 11 year old son last friday in
hartford
when two unknown vehicles approached and
flagged them down around 10 am
the professor who owns property in the
state told police that
one of the drivers a white man said that
he was not wanted in vermont and told to
leave
according to the report he also told
police that there were significant
racial undertones to the interaction
vermont's governor phil scott said he'd
spoken with the victim and added that he
has quote no tolerance for hate crimes
in the state
well you know i have to say i'm not
surprised that jesse smilet
got a job as a college professor but
what the heck is he doing in vermont
that's my question also there are a
number of issues here okay like
what do you mean they flagged you down
so you were driving along
and some white racists flagged you down
to say something racist to you
and you just stopped and listened to
hear them out
it doesn't i can't even make sense of
this
and even if this did happen which i
doubt
couldn't it be that he the guy's from
new york and he has new york license
plates and that's why they didn't like
him
i mean couldn't it be if if if this
really happened my first
thought would be well he's got new york
license plates and these are people that
are worried that he's bringing the
coronavirus into vermont
and so that's why they told him to leave
and
whether it happened or not whether it
was racial or not
why are police investigating it
hate crime the governor's involved
calling it a haker
what crime occurred telling people that
telling someone they aren't welcomed in
the state
how is that a hate crime based on what
law
what law forbids using that phrase to
another person that's what i would like
to know
number four another report from the new
york post says new york
attorney general uh leticia james said
wednesday that she is looking into
reports
that the nypd is targeting minorities
for aggressive enforcement of social
distancing
she says quote in a statement uh the
apparent unequal enforcement of social
distancing policies is deeply troubling
and deepens the divide between law
enforcement
and the people they are tasked to
protect
and then she mentions some videos that
have popped up on social media showing
violent arrests in black and hispanic
neighborhoods
okay so to state the obvious videos
of arrests in black neighborhoods do not
prove or
even indicate that these laws are being
enforced unequally on a racial basis
of course though they are being enforced
unequally
but it's got nothing to do with race the
inequality
is between um the people who've been
subjectively determined to be essential
workers and the people who are who have
been subjectively determined by the
government to be inessential
the inequality is between you know
politicians who keep making a paycheck
while depriving everybody else of their
paycheck the inequalities between small
businesses that are shut down
while mega corporations that sell the
same sort of stuff are allowed to stay
open
okay this is all inequality it's all
injustice
it is something the attorney general of
any state should be looking into
but unfortunately leftists like leticia
james have to see
everything through a racial lens which
means they often
miss the point entirely like is
happening here
um finally a real clear opinion poll
released this week says 40 percent of
americans are more likely to homeschool
once the lockdowns end and
that at least is one good thing maybe
the only good thing to come of
all this now i'm sure that a lot of the
people that are thinking about this it's
just because they're afraid of the virus
and that's why they want to homeschool
their kids but whatever prompts
parents to at least think about uh
consider taking charge of their child's
education well then that's it's good
that they're considering it at least
so maybe that's one that's one thing um
that uh
people will pry their kids loose
from the grip of the state
i think it's good it's something to at
least think about
now let's go to your daily cancellation
this is a fun one i've been looking
forward to this
uh fun for us anyway not so much for the
nfl players
quentin dunbar and deandre baker who are
both being canceled
they're cancelled because allegedly
despite being nfl players and making
millions of dollars to play
a game for a living um they participated
in an
armed robbery a few days ago now the
details in this case
all alleged yes the details are pretty
incredible
bear in mind okay just just to clarify
the cancellation
is because of the sheer stupidity of
this crime
it's it's not because i object morally
to armed robbery on the issue of armed
robbery
i'm sort of in the middle ground i you
know i can see arguments forward and
against it so this is not me passing
judgment on
on armed robbery or armed robbers just
to be very clear about that
anyway let me read from tmz it says
according to police
um the two men were partying in
uh florida on may 13th when things took
a disturbing turn
cops say baker and dunbar were allegedly
hanging out
at a cookout playing cards and video
games when an argument broke out
and baker whipped out a semi-automatic
firearm
cops say the man began to rob party
guests with dunbar assisting and taking
watches and other valuables at the
direction of baker
at one point cops say baker directed a
third man who was wearing a red mask
to shoot someone who had just walked
into the party but fortunately no one
was actually shot
all right um law enforcement says the
men made out with more than seven
thousand dollars in cash
along with several valuable watches
including an eighteen thousand dollar
rolex watch a twenty five thousand
dollar uh
other kind of watch that i can't
pronounce because i'm not rich and then
some other watches too
according to cops some people the party
believe it was a planned robbery because
the three men were
when they were done taking valuables
there were three getaway cars
strategically positioned to expedite an
immediate departure
and the alleged the alleged getaway cars
by the way were a lamborghini
a mercedes-benz and a bmw
okay so first point here obviously is
why weren't they social distancing
that's the real crime here forget about
the armed robbery
the real issue is what what were they
doing at the party in the first place
very very irresponsible behavior during
a pandemic
second they were hanging out at a party
with people they know and
everybody knows them they're there
okay having a good time apparently
argument breaks out
so they say hey you know what might as
well rob the joint
and they rob it and then they run away
and they get in their luxury cars and
they run away
but where are they going everybody knows
who they are
so what's the point this is like when my
couple days ago i caught my
three-year-old sneaking into the pantry
to steal a snack
and i stopped him i said hey and then he
ran away and i'm thinking where are you
going i know who you are
and i know where you're going and i have
a key to every
lock in this house so it's but you might
as well face up to the punishment now
the jig is up
so i'm just this whole thing perplexes
me i um
everything who robs people out of
frustration
like what kind of response is that i'm
not saying i'm the best at conflict
resolution but and
and i get frustrated too it sounds like
they were playing a game one of the guys
got frustrated
i get frustrated too playing board games
um
but it never occurred to me to flip over
a scrabble board and just commit felony
robbery on the spot
out of anger and then the whole fact of
course that again
these are nfl players making millions of
dollars
one of these guys was a first round pick
last year
so i mean he just became a millionaire
recently and now he's out robbing
barbecues
imagine how shocking that is for
everybody else there
that not only are these dudes robbing
you
not only do you know them not only are
you going to be able to id them to the
cops
in in five seconds but they're the
richest dudes at the party
and they're the ones robbing you
which is super super that would be
surprising i guess to everybody but
bernie sanders
who i guess will not be surprised that
rich people are robbing others maybe he
was onto something i don't know
all i can say is that it is it is now
more important than ever that the nfl
season go forward
um we cannot cancel the nfl season look
at what nfl players are doing
after just just just the off season
workouts were canceled
and now you've got two nfl players one
of them a first round pick last year
committing armed robbery of not just one
person
but mass armed robbery
[Music]
just from cancelled workouts can you
imagine
can you imagine if they cancel the
season
imagine what it's going to look like in
like december 2020
if the nfl season is canceled and these
guys have had nothing to do this whole
time
the sheer death toll from nfl players uh
for
the death toll from nfl player related
violence will easily exceed the covet
death
toll so that's that's a pretty good
argument right there i think for keeping
the season going
also i just want to watch football
that's the other argument as well
okay let's go to emails before we do
that i want to take a moment to tell you
about
daily wire's newest most exclusive
membership tier that's all access the
all-access membership tier is our
premier level of membership
all access members get to participate in
all access live which is a brand new
interactive programming feature one of
us daily wire hosts hang out every
night at 8 pm eastern 5 p.m pacific
and you can ask questions with just a
back and forth pretty casual you also
get all the benefits of
our other membership tiers including an
ad free website experience
access to our live broadcast the show
library access to the show's mailbags
all of that all access membership tiers
also include of course
the singular irreplaceable leftist tears
tumbler so head over to dailywire.com
subscribe to join daily wires all access
club with a new membership or an upgrade
and get 10
off with coupon code walsh that's
dailywire.com
subscribe see you there okay
so uh as mentioned if you're a daily
wired member you can send a
email through the mailbag and i'll get
to a couple of those now
this is from michelle says hey matt i
agree with everything you say about
letting people make their own choices
but aren't you walking right into an
obvious response from liberals
if you can make your own choice about
being exposed to the virus or not why
can't women make their own choices over
their bodies when it comes to abortion
you said on twitter quote if you want to
leave your house during lockdown
do it if you don't don't well isn't that
just like the lefts
don't like abortion don't have one logic
yeah michelle i've heard this many times
now and um
no i don't think the two issues are the
same at all i i think that these are two
two very different arguments
here's the crucial difference well there
are two crucial differences
number one abortion is the direct and
intentional
destruction of another person's body it
is the direct and intentional killing of
another person
um it would be completely irrational
and incoherent to claim that a person
who leaves their house during a lockdown
is directly and intentionally killing
another person
as if as if the very point of leaving
is to kill someone is to infect and kill
someone now but here's the thing
if someone actually did you know let's
say someone
knew they had coronavirus and they went
out
because their intention was to infect
people
then i would say yeah i mean i would put
that person in jail if someone dies as a
result i would charge them with murder
of course but the law recognizes a
distinction between
accidentally getting somebody sick even
though you didn't mean to
and getting them sick on purpose and so
that's
so really with related to abortion it's
like the difference between a
miscarriage
and abortion you know in both cases a
child dies and it's tragic but in one
case the mother intentionally and
directly killed the child
and the other case the child died um
by you know accident or illness or
something else
number two um and this is a very
important difference too
the unborn baby cannot
and does not consent in any way to the
abortion
whereas my whole point here with the
shutdown is
you have to in order to be exposed
in order to have any reasonable
likelihood of being exposed
you have to choose to expose yourself to
the potential of getting sick
if you stay locked down you won't be
exposed if you go out and about
then you might be but that's a choice
that you made
um which again the the unborn baby does
not have a choice
so on one hand you have a child being
directly and intentionally killed
without any choice or any consent on
their part on the other hand you have a
person potentially getting sick
unintentionally by accident because
partially they chose to go out and um
and
you know participate in society so those
are i think just not the same at all
okay this is from dan says hey matt
great show definitely been enjoying it
on a daily basis i wanted
to respond to your reaction to the nde
testimonials you were asked about on the
may 13th episode
near-death experience i think the
near-death experience as you
you described were a poor representation
of the case studies which make for the
peaked interest
on the subject if you've read gary
habermas and jp moreland's research you
might find that
they have a more discriminating view on
the subject which makes their findings
on it more compelling
the things you described about seeing
lights and tunnels and universal
religious experiences are subjective and
unverifiable and therefore not very
compelling when it comes to analyzing
these accounts
the more intriguing cases are ones in
which an individual experiences
temporary brain death
in which case they should not they
should have no conscious awareness and
yet can describe
scenes events in the physical world
which from materialism physicalist
perspective
should be incapable of doing such as
seeing on the roof
uh witnessing an accident a few blocks
down overhearing a private conversation
which they can which they could repeat
verbatim
these things can and often are verified
correctly
this says nothing at all about religion
and the mistake people make is jumping
to the conclusions that it does
it merely shows or suggests that
materialism is false or untenable under
these circumstances
there could of course be possible
alternative explanations such as a case
of universally experienced clairvoyance
at the point
maybe they're just lucky guesses it's
possible though arguably unlikely
the important thing to take from these
accounts is not that religion is true
but the materialism is likely false
for materialism to be false does not
prove theism or any religious belief it
is just
merely consistent with it uh anyway
great show keep up the good work
okay yeah dan i i agree that these nds
you describe are far more compelling
and that was my point as you mentioned
that the religious experiences
and experiences of the afterlife are
very subjective and oftentimes
tailored to a person's preconceived
religious beliefs which would seem to
very much call into question
their validity as a scientific proof of
anything
um but then okay what about these cases
of somebody who says they floated to the
top of the room
or they saw something happening down the
road etc
and and those are interesting and i'm
not sitting here saying that they don't
happen
and i'm definitely not accusing people
who who experience them of lying
intentionally that's not my position um
but to say that this happens because the
soul leaves the body
and travels down the street or up to the
roof or whatever
i think raises some difficulties maybe
not insurmountable difficulties but
difficulties
the first is that you know you think
this would be relatively easy
or simple at least to test and and
confirm
but it would need to be in a controlled
environment
like an experimental like a scientific
experiment so you're not relying on
anecdotes
uh or personal testimony which i think
most of the time right when it comes to
the
these ndes what it comes down to is the
personal
testimony anecdotal testimony of a
person who says they experienced it
doesn't make it invalid doesn't make it
uninteresting doesn't
you know nothing like that it just it's
difficult to call it
scientific proof when you're just going
based on what someone tells you happened
right
um so i know
you know why can't they do an experiment
maybe they've done this before i don't
know you tell me
but one thing they could do is you would
think like uh
scientists researchers could place i
don't know um
a note let's say up on a high cabinet in
a trauma ward at a hospital where ndes
typically happen
don't tell anyone what the note says and
then
wait to see if somebody reports floating
to the top of the room
and they can tell you what's on the note
you know
now that might sound silly but if you
want to propose that these are actual
scientific phenomena
then you would need to be able to test
them scientifically
and i think there would have to be some
kind of experiment like that in a
controlled environment
as i said maybe they've done that i
don't know but it strikes me that you
need to have an experiment like that
the other issue i have is just sort of a
metaphysical one you mentioned somebody
who has temporary brain death and then
wakes up and talks about an accident
that happened down the road
now again that's interesting um i'm not
sure if that's an actual case that
you're talking about or a hypothetical
one
but let's just use that now the
skeptical explanation for that
could be yeah lucky guess
or maybe they they heard something about
it uh people talking about it when they
were
when they were you know when it seemed
like they were unconscious they were
still somewhat conscious
they heard discussion of the accident
that happened um
you know those sound like like stretches
but i mean that's a potential
explanation
now the nde believer
what would be your explanation though
like that's what i'm trying to get at
what's the claim here that when you die
or not even die but when you almost die
your soul literally floats out of your
body and travels down the street
that just doesn't seem to make a lot of
sense to me and i say that as someone
who believes in souls i still don't
think that makes sense
um you know we're imagining souls now
as these things that uh
you know in some sense are literally
contained within your body as if they're
like a fluid inside a container
and that when you die or not even die
but just almost die
your soul leaves and
and and travels spatially through the
physical world
down the street and sees something and
then comes back
um i don't know that just seems to raise
metaphysical
questions i can't quite make sense of
that
it raises enough questions that perhaps
the lucky guess explanation
is just more sensible simpler it doesn't
require as many additional explanations
on top of it
and that's the thing i think about
explaining something especially in a
scientific
context if you're if the explanation you
provide
raises more questions than it answers
and there's another available
explanation that answers more questions
than it raises
probably the latter explanation is
better for the time being
so um anyway that's
but but as i said before i'm i'm open to
uh
to more information on that it's
definitely i mean certainly
at a minimum it proves that um
it proves that there's a lot about the
human mind we don't understand so
certainly that and that's why it's
interesting to look into but
um i still think you know i'm far from
convinced i guess that's what i would
say
but thanks for emailing and uh thanks
everybody for watching we'll wrap it up
there
have a great weekend godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there